so you folks are aware if you are
regular listener that this year we are
celebrating 25 years of this radio show
being on the air you know one of the
things I remember looking at as because
I'm kind of as you might guess and
probably figured out pretty
entrepreneurial I see a need in the
marketplace and try to figure out a way
to fill that need it's just how my brain
functions I've always been in business
in one form or another and so I'm always
trying to figure out a way to you know
what is the most efficient way to fill
the need to help somebody and one of our
rules around here is if you help enough
people you don't have to worry about
money so one of things I noticed real
quickly when I got on the air when I
started in this world of speaking and
writing and teaching and trying to help
people with their money was I noticed in
January that people got real focused
there was time for the New Year's
resolutions back in those days the New
Year's resolutions would come out in
something like USA Today and Americans
were polled and the New Year's number
one New Year's resolution is stop
smoking number two is lose weight number
three is get out of debt and number four
is save money or something like that
maybe that's not the order but it was Oh
always those things I'm going to get out
of debt I'm going to stop smoking in a
lose weight and I'm going to save money
which means that two of the four are all
about me helping you get it you know
getting out of debt and saving money and
so you know people are real intense with
their New Year's resolutions usually and
have you notice you can't get a spot in
the gym I mean they look elliptical
machines are all full right the the
treadmills full the weight machine is
full at the gym from January but if
you'll hang around a little bit about
Valentine's Day there's plenty of room
takes about 45 days for people's
enthusiasm to wear off doesn't it and
you know but I knew we could sell a lot
of books I know we could get a lot of
people in Financial Peace University in
January in February we knew there'd be a
big market because people it's funny how
in the rhythm of our life that that
calendar change makes a stop and
reassess what we need to do to improve
what am I going to do better this year
did you do that in January well it's
August where are you are you doing it
what you said you were going to
ingenuine how much of it have you done
now is August I mean we're eight months
in let me tell you what the natural
rhythm also is for most people it's not
everyone but a lot of people then I only
have that January reset in our world we
have noticed that a whole bunch of us
out here have two new years two resets a
year
the second reset is right now middle of
August the kids go back to school
college students head off to the dorm
church attendance goes up vacations wind
down church giving goes up the gyms fill
back up because you got to you know lose
some weight to get ready for
Thanksgiving so you can put it back on
but everybody starts self in the
self-improvement world the world where
you are going to take control of your
life and do better has two times of the
year that it happens it happens in
January and happens again right now in
August it's the natural rhythm of our
culture now some people are more than
others they don't some people don't have
kids that are driving the kiddies back
to school thing some people have you
know different things off a what
vacations over summers coming to a close
football's kicking in people's just your
brain redials it resets and it is the
rhythm of our culture and I don't really
care whether you philosophically agree
with it doesn't matter a whole lot of
people reset their lives again right now
and a lot of you naturally are doing
that and didn't even think about it and
I'm challenging you to think about it
there's some inertia there in the
culture that you can ride what are you
going to do this year this is 2017 the
years not over but we are eight months
in you have an at the natural
inertia of another reset a second new
year right now what are you going to do
are you finally tonight going to open up
the every dollar app and actually do
your freaking budget or are you just
going to listen to the show for
entertainment are you going to reach in
your wallet get out the plastic and
place scissors across it and have a
plastic surgery party tonight like some
candles it's time for a place ectomy the
death of visa is in order have a little
memorial service build a little American
Express coffin ship that thing off to
another planet it's been such a blessing
in your life I actually have had more
than one person telling me the story
that when they got rid of their credit
cards they're back quit hurting now you
think that's silly but you won't one in
a second you ever seen somebody with a
wallet that was four and a half inches
thick looks like a brick in their back
pocket it causes your spine to sit
sideways because you're sitting on a
brick on one of your butt cheeks every
day so think about this it's ridiculous
no wonder your back hurts now one of the
debts causing your back to her get that
junk out of there chop it up chop it up
make a decision to change your life is
the season time to have plastic surgery
time to get on a budget time to sit down
with your spouse and say that's it I've
had it I'm tired of working this hard we
deserve to actually have something to
show for all the crap we put up with you
drive to work among characters who can't
drive putting on their lipstick talking
on their cell phones and eating a Big
Mac on the way to work I mean no wonder
there's road rage these people I was
behind this woman the other day and I
actually got around her and then I was
worried she was going to hit me from
behind because she is driving like she
was completely drunk and all it was is
she's having a
animated conversation with our friend on
the cell phone you drive to work in the
middle of this mess every day you put up
with people at work you put up with
customers at work that are crazy you put
up with all this stuff to my earn a
living for your family you work to that
gum hard to be broke look at how much
money you make and you're broke don't
you think it's time to change well the
natural inertia of our culture says
we're hitting a second new year right
now
middle of August so let's change you
know it's the most powerful human thing
out there power of choice you get to
decide well I'm not good with numbers
the numbers are sixth grade math baby
you can do it if you got out of sixth
grade you can do this stuff you don't
have to have a master's degree in
finance you don't have to understand
calculus you don't have to get a degree
in securities this is not that hard you
just got to care enough to change your
life this is the time to do it right now
right now ready set go
[Music]
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh